[Musica]
sono fatto così
appena ho visto il tema è se dipendesse
da te la prima domanda che mi è venuta
questa se invece non dipendesse da te
e ho pensato che tante cose non
dipendono da noi
spesso le più importanti
ma lo vediamo
si può dir a vivir nuovamente di vita se
potessi vivere di nuovo la mia vita
correrei più rischi
scale ray più montagne farei più viaggi
noterei più fiumi
ma ho 85 anni
e so che sto per morire
la maggior parte di voi non ha ancora 85
anni
e di sicuro ho visto che siamo qui per
fortuna
nessuno di voi sta per morire
come invece stava accadendo a jorge luis
borges quando resa nota questa poesia di
cui vi ho citato alcuni versi sera
cercate si chiama istanti non è sua ha
scatenato una ricerca su chi l'ha
scritta eccetera ma ci interessa quello
che ci ha detto siamo in tempo siamo in
tempo per non trovarci in quella
situazione
siamo in tempo per non rimpiangere le
scelte che potevamo fare e non abbiamo
fatto
e allora userò questi quindici minuti
per prendermi anch'io seguire il suo
consiglio correre un rischio il rischio
di deludere magari un po le vostre
aspettative
e seguirò anche il suo consiglio quello
di fare più viaggi faccio un viaggio in
più vi propongo di fare con un viaggio
un piccolo viaggio
un viaggio che possiamo fare qui
il viaggio che possiamo fare dentro una
parola
dentro una parola che questa sera sarà
al centro del tema dentro la parola
scegliere quando dipende da te scegli e
qualcosa succede
andiamo dentro la parola scegliere
e vediamo che cosa succede
se venite con me il viaggio comincia da
qui
dal punto di partenza
viaggiare dentro una parola significa
prima di tutto
guardarne la superficie dove ci troviamo
e il significato
superficiale
della parola quello che è evidente è
ovvio
scegliere e avere delle possibilità
valutarle prenderne una
rinunciare alle altre
è il punto chiave è prenderne una in
base a che
valutare le possibilità in base a che
cosa
facile
in base alla meta in base ai risultati
in base agli obiettivi che voglio
raggiungere
proprio perché è la superficie il senso
ovvio della parola
ci sembra talmente ovvio
da farci pensare mar
per quale motivo dobbiamo fare sto
viaggio antonio
è già tutto lì è già così chiaro e ovvio
quello che hai detto
e allora il passo più difficile di
questo viaggio è il primo e decidere di
farlo sul serio
e decidere di rompere la superficie per
andare giù e vedere se c'è qualcosa
dentro questa parola oltre la superficie
e lo facciamo perché perché si valutarla
in valutare le possibilità in base agli
obiettivi in base ai risultati in base
credo che sia
il più
deleterio
generatore di ansia della nostra epoca
perché poi succede che gli obiettivi più
delle volte non si raggiungono poi
succede che i risultati il più delle
volte non sono quelli che ci eravamo
proposti
e succede anche che quando li raggiungo
magari li raggiungo a caro prezzo
a prezzo magari del
disastro di altri pezzi di vita o
successo nel lavoro
magari i miei amori non sono così a
posto oppure
rinuncio
a cose che mi piacerebbero però
l'obiettivo che devo raggiungere
e allora proviamo a fare questo viaggio
consapevoli che in realtà i risultati
non dipendono da noi
dipendono dalla fortuna il caso
carmina burana sentitelo opportuno come
luna variabile la fortuna e quell'inno
finisce con quelle due righe indigenza e
potenza
dissolve come ghiaccio
indifferentemente hai raggiunto i tuoi
obbiettivi non esaltarti perché non
dipende da te non hai raggiunto i tuoi
obbiettivi non abbatterti perché non
dipende da te
facciamo questo tuffo il viaggio abbiamo
scoperto è un tuffo rompiamo la
superficie ci tuffiamo nella profondità
della parola scegliere non sappiamo se e
che cosa troveremo ma decidiamo di farlo
nella parola scegliere c'è dentro ex e
leggere
ea sua volta e l'igiene ex leggere
quindi c'è dentro una strana coppia di
due ex e leggere leggere che è leggere
parlare da questa parola
in questa parola c'è anche il logos il
discorso
e poi ci sono questi due ex e dentro
leggere leggere parlare raccontare
discutere in realtà andiamo ancora un po
più in fondo siamo in apnea e proviamo a
resistere ancora andare ancora più giù
la nostra lingua è neolatina e
indoeuropea e indo soprattutto la radice
lag indiana
vuol dire raccogliere ma raccogliere
proprio nel senso del contadino
che raccoglie
da ecco uno degli ex ce lo giochiamo
raccoglie dal suo campo
non da posti qualsiasi il suo campo lo
deve conoscere scegliere intanto ci
parla di un raccolto da fare nel campo
che è nostro
che dobbiamo conoscere di cui dobbiamo
parlare e discutere che dobbiamo saper
leggere che dobbiamo saper raccontare
e raccogliamo raccogliamo le possibilità
così come ci vengono offerte in questo
campo
è però ci avanza
un ex
raccogliere dal campo
e l'altro ex
un altro ex è un'arma l'altra arma che
ci serve perché una volta fatto il
racconto vogliamo scegliere ecco perché
scegliere ne richiede due vogliamo
separare il meglio del raccolto
il meglio delle possibilità che abbiamo
raccolto dal nostro campo che non
dipende da noi perché è lì che viviamo
ma lo facciamo nostro e scegliere il
meglio e scegliere ciò che si impone a
noi
l'apnea
saliamo in superficie tiriamo un sospiro
ci rituffiamo è mica c'è solo l'italiano
chissà cosa ci riserva
l'inglese e poi vedremo il tedesco e poi
vedremo lo spagnolo il cinese il
giapponese no non ho tempo per vostra
fortuna
però facciamo un altro tuffo
scegliere alla superficie in inglese la
stessa cosa choose vuol dire tutte
quelle cose che abbiamo visto in
superficie ma magari se ci tuffiamo hsu
chun scopriamo che sotto ci sono altre
cose e andando giù troviamo che un
sanare un proto germanico vuol dire tu
test to try qui non c'è più raccogliere
ma c'è il senso dello scegliere come
tentare e provare
abbiamo ancora un po di fiato sì andiamo
ancora un po più giù dentro che usano a
c'è di nuovo l'indiano
use
and jews vuol dire non to test vuol dire
to the east non tentare provare ma
provare nel senso di assaggiare
assaporare adesso lo stavo per dire
volevo tenerlo no virus non ci sorprende
che sia anche alla radice della parola
italiano gusto
nel shoes inglese troviamo lo scegliere
come il tentare il provare assaggiando
con gusto
la varietà di ciò che ci si presenta
facciamo l'ultimo tuffo
scegliere in tedesco e belen
vele nella fusione di due pezzi
molto simili cambia solo una vocale come
vedete
è il primo dice volere il secondo dice
selezionare
scegliere lo scegliere tedesco ci dice
che scegliere voler selezionare
scegliere e voler scegliere in qualche
modo c'è questa componente della volontà
che infatti e finiamo in india anche con
loro
è la radice del
che è
al cuore anche della nostra parola
volontà
ma
sorpresa sorpresa non più se ci
ricordiamo della strada che abbiamo del
trucco che abbiamo fatto in inglese
non è alla radice solo della parola
volontà ma anche della parola
voluta
piacere
desiderio
ok
chi vuole magari se
vorrai potrà
provare a fare tanti di questi tuf in
tutte le lingue su una sola parola
a me è piaciuto farlo e
magari può essere piacevole anche per
qualcuno ma
ok però antonio adesso
con tutta questa roba qui dove volevi
arrivare
cosa ci facciamo
non volevo arrivare da nessuna parte
non avevo obiettivi vi ho detto come la
penso su gli obiettivi
volevo fare un viaggio con voi
per scoprire
se oltre la superficie della parola
scegliere che si impone come atto ovvio
per ogni essere umano ci fossero cose
che ci parlassero di modi diversi di
scegliere di valutare che non fossero
quelli
alla fine imposti dall'esterno obiettivi
fuori di noi da raggiungere
e quindi antonio non voleva portarmi da
nessuna parte
se non lasciarvi
forse con un po di confusione in più
ma con un invito
nelle scelte
nelle scelte soprattutto quelle più
importanti
nelle scelte in cui non dipende da noi
quindi uno dice ma perché devo scegliere
è proprio lì
proviamo
a vedere se nel valutare le possibilità
che raccogliamo dal nostro campo per
selezionare le migliori non ci possa
essere d'aiuto
qualche criterio diverso dal
raggiungimento degli
tv usando
questi pezzi questi reperti
che abbiamo scoperto
tuffandoci nella profondità di questa
parola
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]